get a frying pan smoking-hot essential  for quick pan frying  I deliver oil  then seasoned scallops with salt and  pepper starting at the top put clockwise  into the pan so you know which one to  turn first  scallops have firm white sweet flesh and  cooking minutes  next salad lamb's lettuce matchsticks of  Apple  seasoning  lemon zest and juice  at olive oil then toss  turn the scallops when Gordon don't  clockwise around the pan  then squeeze in lemon juice and give the  pan a shake finish with lemon zest  ready in under 10 minutes my first pan  fried dish scallops with crunchy apple  salad  take your figs and sort of place them in  gently  when the chicken skin is crisp turnover  along with the chicory